My kids wanted to play with Lego
and got me to fix it up for them
And so after building for them I
found it was great fun
And I started collecting Lego
I'm Evan Chang, and I'm
doing interior design
I'm actually 38 this year
I collect
a few collections like Lego
Dragonball, One Piece, Bearbricks,
Bruce Lee and a lot of 1/6 figures
So the money spent on all my toys is around six figures
I started off Lego at a later
stage, which was these two/three years
I really respect all the Lego designers,
the way they design the houses,
The details and everything is so nice. For myself my occupation is
doing interior design and I
really like them
It took me half a year to buy everything
back, and and I actually started so late
that you know some of the sets I bought it at a
very high price
And one of it is, the Green Grocer which I actually bought at $3,000
Slowly when I started to build them
There's the fun in it,
seeing the interior, the design of every detail.
Then I actually went to put
in LED lights to light up the city.
Out of my collection
my most prized is Batman series
When I started collecting all
the minifigures series, I liked Batman
so I my friend told me there's a Bible.
so you know I got this book they told me that
this is the book that has all the
Batmans listed inside.
So what i did is I went to Carousell after buying the book
to check every single
one of it and I put a post-it
to tell myself which one I don't have
which one I have, you know from there I
keep buying just a complete the whole
book of it you know within a month
one of the Batmans that I like is the Batman with the bat
which is the the most expensive prized piece that I have
Its a SDCC exclusive and it
cost me $460 just to get this
Right now I'm actually more focused on collecting monotones
The monochrome colours and
collecting all the different colours.
I actually used of my minifig series to match the colors you
know to wash off the prints just to get
the colors of the minifigs
So sometimes one minifig it may go up $100 to get all the parts together.
Sometimes you need to buy four
figures just to complete one.
For stormtroopers when I liked it, the set is already EOL End Of Life
They no longer produce it so
you have to buy it secondhand
So this is actually the box that I'm looking for
The first time getting them was quite funny
I actually went to Carousell to see someone selling at
$25 per box. So I thought, okay great I will get
from him
and he actually mentioned that
how many boxes do you want? And I said,
Fine just let me know how many you have.
I want everything, but I didn't realize that he actually
have 36 box of it.
He told me you have to
transfer the money so I just transferred
the $900 to him and you know within an
hour he actually sent it
So that's how I first got 36 boxes of the stormtroopers.
Slowly because of the amount boxes that
I have, I kept increasing it
After stormtroopers I wanted to buy
Star Wars, to start collecting this new series.
I felt that the R2D2 was very nice
and they told me that R2 is actually
under the Ultimate Collector Series
So in that case what more UCS sets are there
so I focused on buying the UCS
But I haven't complete it's
because most of the old series is very
expensive in the market and I feel that
you know since the new ones coming out I
might as well wait for the new ones
Okay, the funny thing is that
I've never watched Star Wars, the movies or anything.
which means I don't know
anything about Star Wars at all
The most effort put in for all my
toys is the Lego that is in my coffee table
Initially when I planned this, I
actually asked my carpenter in.
So we actually designed the coffee table for it
Then I started to build a train set in it
because I want to have a train at a
coffee table
I don't know how to use those those Lego
programs to build my diorama,
So it was a hands-on process
building and re-doing it until what it is now.
I actually spent three weeks to build it,
But it is not just me alone,
my wife actually got involved
All the trees that stand inside the diorama
were built by my wife
Both of us will spend time together building
this coffee table
and it was not an easy process.
Lego is really fun and it keeps
our family bonded
My wife and I will play Lego together
and even my kids
Our family of four will play together
I had all my figures before I moved in to this flat and designing it
So I knew what I wanted and how to house it.
I love to play with toys and I
like to display them I don't like them
to be in the boxes
I prefer them to be out in
the light and also it's a sign of respect to the toys
Out of my whole house
the favourite part
is actually the doors.
It actually it took me and my
carpenter which we actually sit down to
design it you know to make sure that I
can house all my minifig series every
single row must be at least able to house
from 16 to 20 of it. And I mean I have to
lock it just to be safe in case
my kids took out to play with them
Since starting my collection, I have gotten to know more friends
and we have become very good
friends
we have a group Whatsapp
talking about Legos
One of my groups which we actually call
The Last Order Council, till today I
thought I have a lot of toys but
actually my toy collection is the least
among them all